cuando van a nadar oa ducharse alguna
vez se han preguntado por qué las
células de su cuerpo no se llenan de
agua o porque las sustancias en sus
células no se filtran a la piscina bueno
la razón es porque tenemos una
estructura muy importante que evita que
eso suceda es lo que llamamos membrana
celular la membrana celular es lo que
está en el exterior de una célula
entonces si tenemos una imagen muy
básica de una célula aquí con un pequeño
núcleo en el interior esta capa externa
de color rosa es lo que llamamos
membrana celular la membrana celular
protege a nuestra célula del ambiente
exterior y determina que puede entrar y
salir de nuestra célula ésta es una
propiedad que llamamos semi
permeabilidad es en cierto modo
permeable
algunas cosas pueden entrar mientras que
otras cosas no dado que esta es una
parte tan importante de nuestra célula
de hecho es una de las razones por las
que realmente podemos sobrevivir en el
mundo entonces que constituye realmente
esta estructura bueno el componente
esencial de una membrana celular
es lo que llamamos fosfolípidos hay
otras sustancias que forman nuestra
membrana celular pero el componente
esencial más importante son los
fosfolípidos y los fosfolípidos tienen
tres componentes principales el primero
es una cabeza con un grupo fosfato
el segundo es una columna de glicerol y
el tercero son dos colas de ácidos
grasos entonces la forma en que
dibujamos esto es una cabeza de grupo
fosfato es un círculo y dos colas de
ácidos grasos cuelgan de él como cuerdas
en un globo así que la forma en que
recuerdo esto es que un fosfolípido
parece un globo pero con dos cuerdas
ahora dónde está nuestra columna de
glicerol bueno nuestra columna de
glicerol es en realidad lo que parece es
lo que mantiene las colas de ácidos
grasos unidas a nuestra cabeza de
fosfato es la columna de esta molécula
generalmente no se dibuja en la imagen
pero solo recuerden que está allí y que
mantiene nuestras dos colas de ácidos
grasos unidas a nuestra cabeza de grupo
fosfato esta estructura en realidad
tiene una propiedad muy interesante aquí
arriba esta cabeza es hidrofílica o
polar hidrofílico significa que ama el
agua esta cabeza del grupo fosfato hará
todo lo posible para llegar al agua ama
el agua pero estas colas de ácidos
grasos debido a
son cadenas de carbono muy muy largas
son hidrofóbicas recuerdo hidrofóbico
porque una fobia es un temor o miedo
hidro es agua entonces es miedo al agua
estos dos ácidos grasos harán todo lo
posible para alejarse del agua una
molécula que tiene ambas cosas juntas es
lo que llamamos molécula antipática
significa que la molécula tiene una
sección hidrofóbica y una sección
hidrofílica entonces en el agua que
haría esto digamos que ponemos
muchísimas de estas moléculas en agua
una vez en el agua
las cabezas hidrofílicas quieren estar
lo más cerca posible del agua pero las
colas no entonces lo que sucederá es que
estos grupos fosfatos se agruparán
mientras que las colas intentarán
protegerse o alejarse del agua pero como
esta es una sustancia que está en el
agua el agua también va a estar aquí
abajo por lo que esto formará una
estructura realmente única debido a que
las colas de ácidos grasos comenzarán a
agruparse de esta manera y los
fosfolípidos van a estar al revés
para que las cabezas del grupo fosfato
puedan estar cerca del agua mientras que
esta sección interior puede ser
hidrofóbica y alejarse del agua esto es
lo que llamamos una bicapa fosfolípidos
es una estructura básica de una membrana
celular y como mencionamos esta sección
interior será hidrofóbica así que ahora
tenemos una estructura que se ve así
llamamos a esto nuestra bicapa foxo
lipídica o bicapa lipídica para abreviar
pero acaso esta sección aquí no
interactúa con el agua también como
puede ser esta estructura así si esta
sección toca el agua y sabemos que las
colas de ácidos grasos no quieren tocar
el agua bueno en una célula en la vida
real lo que sucede es que terminamos con
una estructura que forma un círculo como
este esta es una imagen bastante tosca
en una célula esta pared es bastante
delgada en comparación con todo el
cuerpo
entonces notaremos que esta agua ya no
es un problema porque en nuestras
células reales el agua puede estar en él
y en el interior y no importa donde
toque agua esta membrana celular siempre
serán las cabezas de grupo fosfato que
son hidrofílicas las que buscan agua y
dentro de la membrana celular tenemos
una sección hidrofóbica entonces pasemos
a una nueva imagen mencionamos antes que
la membrana celular es semi permeable y
vamos a explorar esto un poco más me he
tomado la libertad de dibujar
previamente una imagen muy larga de una
membrana celular como mencionamos la
membrana celular es en realidad una
esfera que rodea nuestra célula pero
para facilitar esta lección vamos a
dibujarla en línea recta y vamos a decir
que este es el ambiente exterior o
extracelular y este es el interior o
intracelular entonces notamos que la
membrana celular tiene estos
fosfolípidos muy juntos por lo que
generalmente las moléculas pequeñas son
las que pueden pasar a través de la
célula otra propiedad de la membrana
celular que hemos discutido es que esta
sección interna aquí es muy hidrofóbica
por lo tanto las moléculas pequeñas no
polares generan
pueden pasar a través de nuestra
membrana celular esto es lo que llamamos
difusión pasiva entonces cuál es un buen
ejemplo de una pequeña molécula no polar
bueno el tipo más común de molécula
pequeña no polar tienden a ser gases
cosas como por ejemplo el o2 o el co2
estos gases nos rodean todos los días y
nuestra célula en cierto sentido respira
estas moléculas dentro y fuera de ella
por lo tanto los gases pueden pasar
fácil y rápidamente a través de nuestra
membrana celular son pequeños y son no
polares y con que más interactúan
nuestra célula todos los días bueno lo
más común es el agua el agua es una
molécula bastante pequeña y es polar
otra cosa similar al agua es el etanol
esto es como el alcohol que podemos
beber entonces cómo interactúan estos
con nuestra membrana celular bueno
dijimos que a la membrana celular le
gustan las moléculas pequeñas por lo que
éstas pueden pasar a través de nuestra
membrana celular pero nuestra membrana
celular prefiere moléculas no polares
así que estos pasarán muy lentamente y
pueden pasar porque son tan pequeñas que
se escabullen pero muy lentamente porque
a esta región tan hidrofóbica no le va a
gustar tener el agua allí entonces si
tenemos moléculas polares pequeñas que
ocurre con algo que es grande pero no
polar como el benceno el benceno puede
pasar a través de nuestra membrana
celular aunque es grande no es polar por
lo tanto se llevará muy bien con esa
región hidrofóbica en nuestra membrana
celular pero va a pasar muy lentamente
ahora como un dato curioso el benceno
solía usarse en los laboratorios para
que los estudiantes e investigadores se
lavarán las manos pero los científicos
descubrieron que el benceno puede
atravesar nuestra membrana celular y
dañarnos qué pasa con algo que es grande
y polar bueno una molécula como ésta
sería azúcar o glucosa la glucosa en
realidad no puede pasar a través de
nuestra célula es grande y polar es todo
lo contrario de lo que la membrana
celular permite pasar a través de la
célula por lo tanto tendremos que
absorber la glucosa por otros medios
pero
puede pasar a través de la membrana
celular qué ocurre con las moléculas con
carga estas también están por todas
partes cual es un ejemplo de una
molécula con carga bueno algo así como
un ión cloruro o unión sodio o cualquier
tipo de ion otras moléculas con carga
bastante comunes son los aminoácidos y
dado que estos tienen carga son tan
increíblemente polares que tampoco
pueden pasar en resumen nuestra membrana
celular protege a nuestras células y
determina lo que entra y sale una
propiedad que llamamos semi
permeabilidad y esta membrana celular
está compuesta por un montón de
fosfolípidos juntos como la membrana
celular tiene una región hidrofóbica muy
grande
prefiere moléculas no polares y dado que
estos fosfolípidos están tan juntos
nuestra membrana celular también
prefiere que pasen moléculas pequeñas
por lo tanto nuestra membrana celular es
semipermeable lo que permite en general
que pasen moléculas pequeñas y no
polares a través de la membrana celular